y nosotros como pescadores aquí pues
estamos batallando porque no hay no hay
este pesca suficiente para sostén de
nuestras familias y algunos compañeros
optan por salir a buscar trabajo a la
ciudad y así como está ponerse más y más
duro este pues se me hace que vamos a
quedar aquí solos
[Música]
y
y es mucha la sequía que hemos tenido
durante varios años ya que no hay ningún
apoyo de gobierno del estado en el
gobierno federal de ninguno no hay
ningún apoyo
pero nosotros como productores pues no
tenemos la capacidad y menos que tenemos
unos años con poca agua
nos estamos estamos de escape
descapitalizados necesitamos el apoyo y
no que nos regalen no estamos impuestos
a que nos regalen estamos impuestos a
trabajar ya cumplir con nuestros
compromisos
la producción se ha escaseado demasiado
y los forrajes por lógica suben se
escasean y suben entonces este sí sí sí
se está complicando en la situación
y necesitamos la lluvia pues es lo que
nos abastece